so Amir gilad is going to be the next
speaker and his talk is on the
accessibility and privacy of provenance
based
explanation you mut yes yes okay great
now you can hear me yes okay so uh this
talk is going to be based on
collaboration with Daniel yal Na and
a so we know that Providence is an
incredibly useful tool for understanding
processes that involve data debugging
the data justifying uh the query results
Etc however in its raw form H it may be
unusable in certain you uh for certain
situations so for example provenance can
be very long and complex like in this
polom and this can make it difficult for
users to parse and understand especially
if they're not
experts second provenance can also be to
revealing in certain applications where
the query needs to remain confidential
so for example showing providence-based
explanations can reveal the underlying
query that generated them so in this
talk I want to discuss different
post-processing options for provenant to
make it suitable for specific
applications so I'll talk about uh two
works and uh I'll do it in two parts in
the first part I'll talk about
provenance explanations in natural
language and how we developed a specific
mechanism for provenance factorization
and summarization for such
explanations in the second part I'll
talk about abstract in provenance for
the sake of maintaining the privacy of a
confidential qu so both uses of
provenance involves some sort of
provenance manipulation to make it
suitable for the specific
usage so let's consider the first
scenario where we aim to make provenance
based explanations
accessible so we know that it's usually
difficult for users without Technical
Training to query the database and even
experts sometimes find it hard to
formulate a query uh that they want
since they have to know the exact schema
of the database so this is where natural
language interfaces come into play Such
interfaces allow users to ask their
queries in English and get the results
so let's see a use case so let's
consider this natural language query
over an academic research database
return the organization of authors who
publish papers in database conferences
after 20
5 uh when this uh query is inputed to a
natural language interface it's
translated into this formal
query which is then evaluated over the
database and the results are shown to
the user now one of the results is Duke
University a user who gets this result
may now wonder why is this part of the
result set or why does it answer the
conditions they specified in the
question so what we would like to show
is a clear and concise natural language
explanation for the result like this one
Duke is the organization of 63 authors
who published 170 papers in 31
conferences in 2006 till
2015 so I'll quickly demonstrate our
provenance model so reconsider this
natural language query so HH this is the
the uh the formal query when and when
it's evaluated over the
results we we consider a value level
Provence so H here we see the provence
polinomial where each monomial
represents a single assignment that
resulted in the result Duke University
and it's composed of pairs where each
element is H the variable and the second
second element is the value to which it
was mapped to by the assignment so for
example here we see the assign one of
the assignments leading to the result
Duke and uh the colors denote some of
the variables from the database map to
the values so not all variables appear
in this polinomial for
Simplicity so now let's go back to our
problem and when we tried to solve the
problem ER of translating raw provenant
to natural language explanations we
tackled two main challenges the F first
is that the formal model of Provence is
very far from a natural language
sentence is and second the provence of
even a single result can be very long
and convoluted and we use the structure
of the input question to tackle both
challenges for the first challenge we
use the structure of the input question
as the basis for the structure of the
answer and for the Second Challenge we
shorten the provenance by factorizing it
and use the input question as a
Criterion for generating only
factorizations that are suitable for
natural language answer
generation so I'll quickly go over our
framework first the user inputs a
natural language question into a natural
language interface in this case we used
a ner which is based on a 2015 vldb
paper
nir then parses the input question
generating a dependency tree and it also
Maps the words of the questions to
tables of the database while translating
the question into a formal qu during
this process our augmented version
stores both the dependency tree and the
mappings from words to the of the
question to variables of the query the
formal query is then
evaluated H using the Providence aware
evaluation engine LP H which is based on
our 2015 VB paper and once we have the
provenance the results and the mappings
we factorize the provenance and either
generate a sentence based on the
factorized provenance or further
summarize the provenance and then
generate a
sentence so let's demonstrate the
explanation generation process for a
single assignment first so on the left
we see see the dependency tree of the
question with the mappings to pairs of
variables and values from the database
for example the word organization was
mapped to the variable o name which was
mapped by the assignment to the value
Duke from the
database so once we have the dependency
tree and the mappings we would like to
convert them to An Answer Tree in order
to make an answer sentence so we now
consider the part of speech and
relationship of the words in the
question given to us by the dependency
tree also and based on this information
we augment the dependency Tree by either
adding the mapped value as a node in the
tree or replacing the mapped word with
the value mapped to
it so for example the value Duke which
was mapped to the word organization is
added as its child while the value
junyang map replaces the word authors to
which it was
mapped
so once we have the answer tree we
convert it to a sentence by reversing
the mappings from words to values and
considering the location of the words in
the original natural language qut So
based on these and the answer tree we
generate the sentence Duke is the
organization of jun young who published
I Che in Sig mode in
2014 so now let's consider the general
case where a single result can stem from
multiple
assignments one possible solution is to
generate a separate sentence for each
assignment however this would result in
a long explanation that would be
difficult and tedious for the user to
read so instead we employ the already
known concept of factorization which is
similar to the concept H discussed in
previous talks in this workshop and we
generate a single sentence containing
all assignments
so consider the provenance polinomial
that we've seen before but but this time
we only show the
values here are two different
factorizations of this expression the
left one is the shortest factorization
of the expression and the right one is a
longer
factorization now the standard in
previous work has been looking for the
shortest factorization since it's the
best solution in terms of storage of the
Providence but recall that our goal is
to generate a natural language question
so is the shortest factorization the
best solution in our case as well and
here's a hint the intuition here is that
we want a factorization that follows the
structure of the input question so it'll
be easier to generate an answer sentence
from
it so let's reconsider the natural
language question that we had and the
factorization that we've just seen the
shortest factorization so at the bottom
here we see a reasonable sentence based
on the structure of the
factorization so first note that this is
not a clear sentence and what's more the
red parts are not part of the question
so it's not clear how to automatically
generate
them so let's see what happened on the
right
we see the dependency tree of the
question and on the left we see the
factorization now notice that the word
authors is an ancestor of the word
conferences in the tree however in the
factorization the value Jun yangang
which was mapped to the word authors
appears lower in the hierarchy than the
value sigmod mapped to the word
conferences so the hierarchies are
reversed and the structure of the
factorization is disconnected from from
the structure of the input
question however if we consider the
longer factorization that we've seen
this factorization maintains the
hierarchies between the words of the
original question and we get a clear
sentence for it based on the structure
of the question so a factorization that
maintains these hierarchies is called T
compatible since it is compatible with
the dependency
tree
so therefore our algorithm uses the
dependency tree as a guide to obtain T
compatible factorizations using a greedy
approach which revers the dependency
tree from top to bottom and for each
level of mapped words we take out the
values ma to these words prioritizing
based on the frequency of the values at
each
level so the complexity is n s time log
n since we have to Traverse all n nodes
and for each level of mapped words
possibly sort the values according to
the
frequency and we get the guarantee that
this algorithm will generate a t
compatible
factorization that can be transformed to
a natural language
explanation so now an answer based on a
factorization can still be too long at
times so we can shorten it even more
using provenant summarization
we build on the provence factorization
that we generated in the previous step
and choose the level at which we want to
summarize we assume that we have a
summary functions for each value type
that we can apply to the values and if
we choose a specific level we summarize
all levels below it to ensure that we
get a t compatible fact summarized
factorization so choosing a higher level
means that we get a shorter but less
informative answer like with the
brackets a If instead we summarize at a
lower level like with the brackets B we
would get a longer answer containing
more details for example the author
names and users can experiment with
different levels of
summarization so uh to assess the
quality of our system you can see uh a
few examples of the question questions
and the uh answers and explanations that
our system
provided H we've also asked in our paper
for external users to formulate their
own queries and examine the explanations
that they got so for example for the
question return the authors published
papers in vldb before 2016 and after
2007 we got the summarized answer for
Tova Milo Tova Milo published 16 papers
in vldb in in 2008 till
2015 so now I'd like to talk about a
different uh problem and this problem ER
relates to abstracting Raw Providence
for maintaining the privacy of a
confidential
court so consider this
scenario a company performs a
proprietary query over a database to
determine whether us it a US should be
targeted for an ad the user is then
shown the ad and if requested also a
personal explanation for why they were
shown this ad so this scenario has been
addressed to some extent by large
companies trying to provide explanations
for
ads so suppose for example that James
and Brenda are shown an ad for a dance
music album and they'd like to know
why the system can provide each of them
with with a personalized explanation
based on their data so for James it's
the fact that his hobby is dance
according to Facebook and he's
interested in music according to
WikiLeaks for Brenda it's the fact that
her hobby is dance according to LinkedIn
and she's interested in music according
to
Facebook so now let's assume that James
and Brenda are friends and share their
data and explanations so we can mod this
scenario with a small database
representing a database for the
information about social networks so
it's composed of three tables the right
one shows the ID of each person the
middle one shows for each person ID
their Hobbies according to different
sources and the leftmost table shows for
each person their interests according to
different
sources so the problem now is that James
and bnda
can reverse engineer the general
Criterion on the basis of which the
company decides to show the ads in fact
our previous work has shown that in many
practical cases it's enough to show only
a very small number of providence-based
explanations to successfully reverse
engineer the
court however if we keep the
explanations at a higher level reverse
engineering the general criteria would
become more difficult so in our example
if we tell James that the reason he was
shown this ad is some information from
Facebook and it was published on
Wikileaks that he's interested in music
and tell Brenda that the reason she was
shown the ad is due to some information
from LinkedIn and because she's
interested in music according to
Facebook this would make it more
difficult for James and Brenda to detect
the underlying query for showing this ad
to
people so let's shortly discuss our
model so here again we see the database
tables that we that we've seen before
below them H we cons we see the formal
query now in general we consider uqs but
we can extend our models to aggregate
functions as
well and the query will return the IDs
of people whose hobby is dance According
to some source and whose interest is
music according to another
source so here is one satisfying
assignment to the query that yields
James's ID with a colorcoded topples to
show the satisfying assignment so in
this case we model the pro the
provenance using the NX semiring uh
which is the product of the IDS of the
topples h but in general we can support
other H commutative suar rings as
well so we assume that this provenance
is the basis for the explanation shown
to the
users so now we can Define what is a
provenance exam so recall that James and
Brenda both had different explanations
that they share so the model uh to model
this we use a table with two rows and
each row contains the output of the
query along with a provenance generated
by the query while producing the
output so now I'd like to talk about
provenance abstraction so this concept
has been considered by previous work as
means of reducing the size of the
provenant to make its storage more
efficient so here we'll use it for a
different person uh purpose namely to
make the explanations more vague so
reconsider the three database tables
that we've seen before and the tree
below them this is an abstraction an
abstraction tree that groups topples in
the database according to their source
so for examples for example the topples
I3 H2 and H5 were obtained from LinkedIn
so they're grouped together under the
node LinkedIn in the tree the notes
Facebook and Linkedin are then grouped
under the parent social network and this
is just one example of such a tree in
general there can be multiple options
for such abstraction trees even for the
same
database so now let's consider the
abstraction tree that we've just seen
and below is the provenance example
representing James and Brenda's
explanation for the
ad we can make the provenance in the
example abstract ra by replacing some of
the tle identifiers with one of their
ancestors in the tree so in this example
we replace H1 with Facebook and H2 with
LinkedIn so now that we have an abstract
provenance example notice that there are
several tles that can replace each of
the symbols Facebook and Linkedin so
mely these are the children of Facebook
and Linkedin therefore there can be
several queries that generate the
provenance and H output the
corresponding ID so here are three
examples of such queries and all three
will generate the output of the
provenant that can be abstracted to the
one shown on the
slide however since we know that James
and Brenda are intelligent users we
can't fool them with just any set of
queries and think that they'll fall for
it so the dummy queries or the candidate
queries need to make sense if we want to
hide the real query so this is the
reason that we have criteria for the
candidate
queries so first each query needs to be
connected so every predicate in the
query needs to share a variable or a
constant with another predicate in the
query so in this case all three
predicates share the variable
ID the queries also need to generate
concrete provenant that can be
abstracted to the provenant in the
example when generating the output so
this property is called
consistency and third the queries need
to be inclusion minimal there is no
other consistent query is contained in
such a candidate query so this ensures
that the query is a tight criteria am
you have about five minutes left okay
yes okay so if Case such queries ER fit
the abstract provenance example we say
that its privacy is
K so when we abstract the provenance we
gain privacy but we lose specific
information about the provenance and
hence the explanation so every time we
replace a tuple with its ancestor we
have multiple ways of interpreting the
Providence so consider the abstraction
tree that we've seen and this abstracted
Providence example with the symbol i1
replaced by
Reddit there are four ways of making the
provenance concrete again and this
defines a probability space over the set
of possibilities where each possibility
has a probability associated with it so
to quantify the loss of information we
use entropy over all options to make the
provence
concrete so now we're ready to define
the problem that uh we want to solve and
the problem is to find the optimal
abstraction and more formally given an
abstraction tree a provenance example
and a privacy threshold K we want to
find an abstraction for the example that
achieves privacy at least K and incurs
the minimum loss of information over all
abstractions that achieve the Privacy
threshold K so this problem turns out to
be NP hard and this can be proved by
reduction from vertex
cover so to nevertheless find the
optimal
abstraction we do iterate over all
possible abstractions but we can
eliminate most of them quickly using
practical
optimization so here we see the
abstraction tree and the Providence
example that we
know and here are several abstractions
that we start to iterate over so we can
quickly eliminate the first one since it
does not meet the Privacy threshold and
we don't actually need to generate all
the queries to see that and the idea
behind this optimization is H is
Computing the Privacy row by row and
removing the disconnected ques along the
way so we can then eliminate the second
abstraction since it does not minimize
the loss of information compared to the
leftmost
abstraction and we continue in this way
until we get the optimal abstraction so
the guarantee of this algorithm simply
by the property of iterating all overall
obstructions is that it returns an
optimal so here's a sample of the
experiments that we
conducted and here we measure the
runtime as a function of the Privacy
threshold for a tpch and IMDb data set
and queries and we see that increasing
the threshold even to 20 does not
significantly increase the runtime
showing the uh the performance of the
algorithm so to
summarize we've seen two different ways
of manipulating Provence to make it fit
natural language explanation and for
maintaining
privacy H we've shown that we can
factorize and summarize problem to make
it understandable and concise for
explanations but also we've shown that
we can abstract provenant to make it
preserve the privacy of quaries so our
tools were the dependency tree for
natural language explanations that
served as a guide for generating
suitable
factorizations and the abstraction tree
where we used it as a guide for
generating private
Providence so we also talked about the
tradeoff when summarizing or abstracting
provenant where naturally shorter
summarization or more abstract provenant
yields less informative
explanations so we are now considering
several extension to the to these works
one of them is incorporating llms with
natural language
explanations and uh making
the natural language explanation
system usable both with llms as well and
the second is a different privacy
Criterion for provenance whereas in the
first work if you notice I didn't
mention it by name but the Privacy
Criterion was based on K anonymity we
can also think about other maybe more
robust ER criterions like differential
privacy for
quars so thank you
everybody thank you thank you yeah Val
has a
question Amir so I apologize if you had
an example in the first part of your
talk in which you actually had some
provenant that had a
coefficient uh I don't know something
like think of a bullan query
problem is 2 p squ or something like
that if there is so how do you treat it
in the natural language explanation what
do you say about that
coefficient so uh if this is a if this
is a
coefficient that would mean there's a a
self jooin right no not necessarily um
it
may that you have a like think of the
query um bullan query does Amir gillad
have any Sig mod papers coauthored with
Daniel Deutsch right and there are many
so you will actually get a whole bunch
of them but you only track the fact
that uh you maybe only track the fact
that your quter is Daniel or something
like that so you can have something like
that even without a self joint
yeah yeah so I I think in this case uh
we would separate the the we would
basically write it out as the full
assignment um without the coefficient so
write out the full expression without
any short uh without any uh short
handwriting with coefficients and then
factorize it in some of your
explanations there were numbers like
junan had 64 papers and so that 64 did
not come via this route right right it
came it came via a summarization of the
the number of values of the same type
thank
you okay so uh let's take a break
because we are uh running late but we
will start the next session on time at
11: so Benny bre and Amit Daniel could
you be back like five minutes before 11
Pacific please okay thank you and
let's